es könnte eine der letzten langen
Kreuzberger Nächte gewesen sein Berlin
am vergangenen Wochenende die Clubs
brechend voll nur das Coronavirus das
soll draußen bleiben
die Reduktion von Kontakten das ist das
A und O und darum wird es in den
nächsten Wochen gehen für ungeimpfte ist
die Party in Deutschland vorbei mit
Flächen Decken dem Zweig will die
Politik die vierte Corona Welle Brecht
wer der Meinung ist dass das kein
scharfes Schwert gegen die Pandemie sei
der weiß ich nicht wie man ihm helfen
kann
Genesende und geimpfte unter sich ist
das der Weg hinaus aus der Pandemie
zwei gegen wird können wenn es überall
flächendeckend nicht nur angewandt
sondern auch also kontrolliert wird
doch wie gut wird kontrolliert eine
Stichprobe im Berliner Nachtleben wir
drehen mit versteckter Kamera
könnt ihr euch bei Luca einchecken und
ich müsste euren Impfpass sehen klar
danke
erste Bar erste Kontrolle der Impfpass
wird nicht überprüft der Personalausweis
nicht kontrolliert auf Nachfrage
schreibt uns der Inhaber wir glauben an
die Zweig Maßnahmen sie sein aber ein
Mehraufwand da müsste man die Balance
waren ein paar Läden weiter am Eingang
ein großes Hinweisschild Zutritt nur mit
Zweig eine Kontrolle aber findet nicht
statt in der Bar entspannter Atmosphäre
dicke Luft und dichtes Gedränge dabei
hatte Berlins Bürgermeister die
Ordnungsämter zuvor noch angemahnt die
Umsetzung von 2G zu kontrollieren ganz
genau hinzuschauen
im Moment geht es um Prioritätensetzung
es geht im Moment nicht um Falschparker
sondern es geht um Menschenleben
Mitarbeitern des Ordnungsamt beim
Kontrollgang sind wir an diesem Abend
nicht begegnet
2G das zeichnet sich nach dem Abend in
Berlin ab wird wohl eher nicht der Weg
aus der Pandemie sein das müssten auch
die neu gewählten Abgeordneten wissen
eine Expertenanhörung im
Bundestagsausschuss vor einer Woche
[Musik]
wir werden auch über weitere Maßnahmen
über diesen Katalog hinaus in den
nächsten Wochen sprechen müssen und den
auf den Weg bringen weil wir sind in
einer absoluten Notlage die politische
Lage das muss man so deutlich sagen ist
eigentlich seit dem
sie immer wieder der wissenschaftliche
hinterher
ach du wir müssen überall den gleichen
Ansatz wählen wir müssen uns zivilisiert
verhalten und uns mit den Beschränkung
auf die ungeimpften konzentrieren statt
auf die gesamte Bevölkerung
noch im Juli beschließt Frankreich 3G
für Freizeitparks Kinos und Konzerte
andere Töne in Deutschland
deswegen ist es geboten auch Freiheiten
wiederherzustellen die stehenden
Menschen zu und so wird es sicherlich
auch weiterhin Lockerungen geben müssen
im August Frankreich verschärft mit 3G
in Cafes Einkaufszentren und Zügen
Deutschland will weiter öffne die
Pandemie Lage und er impft Fortschritt
erlauben nach unserer Überzeugung schon
jetzt die Aufhebung vieler freiheits
Einschränkungen
im September verpflichtet Frankreich
alle Beschäftigten im Gesundheitswesen
zu Impfung gegen massiver Proteste
Deutschland ruft nach Freiheit besonders
laut die FDP ich will jetzt nicht
überschreiten und einige Daten sagen wir
brauchen den freedomday so schnell wie
möglich bei den Menschen mittlerweile
mental am Ende sind
Frankreich kommt bislang besser durch
den Herbst weil ich das Land im Sommer
vorbereitet hat als die Politik
hierzulande anderweitig beschäftigt war
der Wahlkampf hat sich im Kern man muss
es so deutlich sagen aus verschiedenen
Gründen aus in keiner Weise und Corona
gedreht keiner hat wirklich die Warnung
der Wissenschaftler wirklich ernst
genommen und insofern fällt jetzt etwas
dramatisch auf uns zurück was wir im
Sommer hätten vorhersehen können
gab es auch in Deutschland das
Robert-Koch-Institut trieb die
Bundesregierung schon im Juli zur allein
aufgrund eines wahrscheinlichen Anstieg
der Fallzahlen sollte die aktuell
entspannte infektions lade jetzt genutzt
werden um präventive Maßnahmen für den
Herbst und Winter vorzubereiten
z.b. durch
Beschränkungen von Teilnehmerzahlen an
Veranstaltungen doch im Gegenteil wurden
die im Sommer praktisch aufgehoben
das RKI forderte technische
Möglichkeiten zur Luftreinigung sprich
Luftfilter doch die gibt es nach wie vor
so gut wie nirgends
dass er carimate Booster Impfungen
sollten jetzt geplant und vorbereitet
werden in Deutschland aber wurden im
Sommer reihenweise Impfzentren
geschlossen
die Bundespressekonferenz am vergangenen
Freitag Fragen an den Präsidenten des
Robert-Koch-Instituts die haben ja auch
im Sommer gewusst was auf uns zukommt
Hameln letzten Tagen sehr drastisch
gewarnt aus heutiger Sicht hätte das
früher passieren müssen das
Robert-Koch-Institut dass jede dieser
vier Wellen rechtzeitig vor Ausgang jede
dieser vier werden wie oft habe ich hier
gesessen
Professor Torsten sagt er wird kein
Papagei ich bin schon lange der Papagei
wie oft habe ich hier gesessen und habe
das immer wieder gesagt
also
so ist es einfacher das sind die Fakten
und die sollten auch alle nicht
vergessen und fakt ist Deutschland
rutscht wieder Richtung Lockdown hier im
Erzgebirgskreis gelten schon wieder
Ausgangs Beschränkungen und
übernachtungsverbot das Berghotel
Bärenstein im März 2020 kurz vor dem
ersten Lockdown hat Dennis Feist das
Geschäft übernommen jetzt geht das Drama
von vorne
Fricktaler alles jetzt weg ganze Hotel
ist leer momentan und da habe ich ja
heute Kurzarbeit angemeldet zu 100% die
Weihnachtsmärkte in Sachsen müssen
schließen bevor sie überhaupt geöffnet
haben vor alles schön fertig war alles
verkaufsbereit
scheiße
[Musik]
Prost auch über die vielen ungeimpften
nirgends gibt es davon mehr als in
Sachsen nirgends passiert das
Coronavirus stärker ich sag einfach mal
wenn sich die jeder mag geholt hätte die
Impfung dann werden wir nicht in der
Lage Beamer heute sind
Impfungen hätten die 4. Welle
abgeschwächt um sie zu brechen bräuchte
es aber im Pfoten von weit über 80% sagt
dass er keine andere europäische Länder
sind ja beide noch Mitte Juli lagen
Deutschland Spanien und Portugal bei
rund 30% vollständig geimpft und im
Wettlauf gegen das Virus damit gleichauf
doch schon kurz darauf zündeten die
Staaten im Süden der Union den vaccin
Turbo das Resultat mittlerweile liegen
Spanien und Portugal mit über 80%
doppelt geimpft an der Spitze bei
vergleichsweise niedrigen Inzidenz
Deutschlands Importe dagegen stagniert
bei rund 68% den seadance dagegen steigt
auf mittlerweile 400 und auch der Druck
auf umgehend besteigt erste Zahlen
zeigen es wird nicht alle hier an der
Leipziger im Stelle sind zum Bus dann da
die 4. Welle werden diese Impfungen
nicht mehr stoppen und auch 2G wird
nicht reichen selbst wenn einige Klops
wie dieser inzwischen akribisch
kontrollieren so kommt Deutschland dem
nächsten lockdownd Schritt für Schritt
näher das Wahlversprechen von der
Rückkehr zur Normalität ist erweist sich
als kurzlebig
[Musik]